hello everybody in uh vaynerland it is
me gary vaynerchuk i'm here with
two of my friends uh as you can see i'm
gonna wait for the comments to come in
uh dustin i don't see the comments
coming in usually i do but you'll let me
know on that i know we're just getting
live now you can go live on the gram but
if you are watching in all the other
platforms
uh once again i'm going to wait for the
comments to come in that usually there
we go
john p from facebook's in the building
cody see in the building navra so
facebook is kicking in i see all the
facebook comments i'm gonna wait for
some of the other platforms there is
youtube youtube good to see you this is
a little impromptu breaking news
i'm in the breaking news business now
with uh matt novogratz and shane small
we will be giving you some very exciting
information
um i am live on instagram instagram what
is good
more of this
instagram is not integrated into stream
yards so if you want to see this live
from the full perspective especially
because we're about to unveil something
that has never been seen before please
go to my youtube my linkedin or my
facebook my twitter every other channel
uh everybody i'm going to give a couple
more minutes for this to populate but uh
shortly
um
there'll be a url down here and that
will be
a url that all of you should join the
discord
of candy
the platform that the three of us work
on
as many of you know i'm a board member
to that these two gentlemen are in the
day to day i'll let them introduce
themselves in a second but the reason i
want you to join the candy discord is
we've got about 48 hours
before we take a snapshot of everybody
who's in the candy discord
and
what we will be doing with those people
is giving them first access
on the baseball project that candy is
putting out many of you have been
focused on some of the baseball stadium
stuff a lot of you were doing sweet
futures which is the college football
stuff
but the big one this is the big one the
baseball product our core baseball nft
will be coming out shortly and right
here live on my socials
we will be
giving the first look
to this incredible project that we're so
excited about and so that is the setup
please start sharing the url
once we get it in there
uh oh there it is garyvee.com
candy and
great
last gary
gary
give me one second
he'll be back there he is i'm always
back clicking just about start juggling
i was gonna do some great like i've got
some great improv stuff
you could put that was my click wrong
error uh garyvee.com
candy nft please everybody who's here
right now
please share that url i don't know if
the gary and the g and the vr are they
caps
has to be cap sensitive usually for that
making i think
the the candy nft part is case sensitive
but i don't think the garyvee part is
but nonetheless please please everybody
click that in
uh try it right now and if it works and
it sends you to the candy discord um
please start sharing it in all the chats
on youtube uh facebook uh all that stuff
so anyway um
i'm excited to share this and please get
into the candy nft
um
discord because that is the
secondary most important part of what
we're doing here because we're taking a
snapshot in 24 to 72 hours i don't know
the exact logistics but who's ever in
the discord
is going to be part of this alpha which
is going to allow them to buy the
baseball nfts which in my opinion have
enormous upside against the cost of the
packs and now i will let matt and shane
introduce themselves individually and we
will get to
the
place
hey thanks gary um yeah the facts are
gonna be pretty awesome right like uh it
is case sensitive
all lower case
so it's all even the garyvee part i'm
sorry maddie
all lowercase all right dustin you're
doing that i see a lot of people go
through it beautiful i see scott and
others everybody who here who got there
please share it in the comments matt
take it away yeah i'm just gonna say
look these packs are gonna be awesome
right like we definitely we hint a bit
to the past with uh collectibility um
rarity structure um but we also have
super cool unlockables the one of ones
are going to have some experiences
involved uh you know october 26th they
these drop
so in 20 days we are dropping this
somebody just asked in the comments is
the mlb involved the mlb is uber
involved the mlb and the mlbpa has
licensed to candy the rights these are
the official official nfts correct
maddie yeah the first drop is going to
have two subsets the one of which is
going to be the all-stars everyone was
an all-star team the 81 all-stars of
this year and then another subset we're
calling uncut diamonds which will be the
top prospect for each of the 30 teams
which to me i'm super excited for that
set
shane who are you besides being
stunningly attractive and trendy
uh you know gary thank you
i've been trying to tell my wife the
same thing for years
and so i'm gonna use that as a clip just
as we go to bed tonight gary v said that
so
let's keep that marriage going
um i head up creative
um
so
really looking at how we approach nfts
uh how we approach them in a meaningful
way
um
i i mean i really see this space as an
opportunity to
not be creating these collectible
digital assets
but more create these collectible
digital experiences
my thing is that i i look for
in the approach creatively i'm looking
for story to be told to the audience and
that's any of our products that hero a
hero
or a fan
we'll be able to deliver the story about
that hero but i'm also looking for that
story that the consumer has with our
content
the one that delights the one where you
feel like you've discovered something
the one that feels immersive
that's really what i'm looking for
because that story that you tell your
friends about a personal experience that
you had with our product in some way
those are the foundations that we're
starting to build for our content right
now
so i head up the
the thinking the aesthetic with an
unbelievable team
that makes me look good every single day
so a lot of people tuning in i know that
i haven't gone live on all my platforms
and not i know that all of you haven't
seen all my information on nft's
non-fungible tokens maybe you've heard
about be friends at this point maybe
other projects like board api club or
nba top shot
the biggest comp is probably to nba top
shot given the licensing rights the nba
gave dapper labs an incredible company
the rights to the nba top shop they made
a highlight product what you're about to
see is what we've done with mlb and i
think without further ado we should show
it especially because i have a client
meeting in a second so this is just a
breaking news scenario so why don't we
show the video this is the first look
to the candy baseball product that we
are incredibly excited about
[Music]
so
[Music]
love
love
so i think you know what i love about
this is you see how the product ends
shane what i think you did extremely
well
is it's dynamic
but then it ends as
a card as a more static you know it's
got the elements of the new age things
that you can do differently than a card
but it ends like a card but all the
dynamic things are happening that lends
itself into that incredible piece of
fernando tatis
my thing is that i'm really looking at
building narratives that connect with an
audience
story is very important to me in terms
of how we
how we um express these heroes these
um
and really appease the fans through that
narrative i don't want to just give a
cool picture that that's uh fernando
states but i want to tell his story in a
way that feels dynamic so i have context
and yes it will come into a 3d card at
the end and again we're also looking at
tying dynamic stats with it i want to
build utility again immersive
experiences we have this road map we're
in the infancy of this and when we stop
building out that road map it's going to
be something that i'm hoping is going to
blow people's minds
novo any uh parting shots before
we definitely we're going to borrow from
the past as well right while we connect
to the future like you saw that right
and that's that's what we're excited
about we're collectors first we want
these to feel like collectibles um
everybody uh one more time dustin i know
there's been a lot of confusion with the
url but a lot of people have been
sharing it i just tweeted it there it is
for everybody who's watching
um
uh i think that um
i i think that the assets are incredible
i think shane did it and the team did a
remarkable job i think the product
launch is unbelievable wait till you see
how affordable the pricing is
i'm going to say it loud and clear
i'm really busy a lot of you been seeing
i haven't been talking about v friends
for last 30 days i jumped in for this
breaking news with my two teammates here
on the candy side for one reason and one
reason only they rightfully so wanted
people to get a little preview of the
content i'm happy to do that i'm here
for a totally different reason this url
that you're looking at garyvee.com
the nft gets you into the candy discord
the candy discord like every other nft
project the discord is the central hub
but nobody knows and i'm not even sure
i'm supposed to be saying this so no i
apologize but i know and i'm telling my
audience and obviously i know they'll
get out is we're going to take a
snapshot of who's in the discord pretty
quickly here
you know i i i heard right right novo
like pretty quickly we're gonna take a
snapshot and that will be the beta crew
aka the people that can buy these packs
i think that is gonna matter because
this is a very as big as my audience is
this is
0.0001 of the world just got to see what
it looks like i think a lot of you
realized it looks remarkable the pricing
is ridiculous it's the all-stars of
baseball and some rising stars and
they're going to sell out very fast and
there's going to be a secondary value so
if you're in the discord dustin i don't
know what you're doing by pulling it off
put it back up because it's the only
thing that [ __ ] matters because it's
the arbitrage
garyvee.com
candy nft get into the discord start
talking to people there's been people
there collecting the sweet futures which
is our college football product you
should get some of those as well but
this baseball product is major league
baseball and major league baseball
players association's official product
from candy coming october 20th is what i
heard from novo is that right 26 the
first day of the world series
uh i couldn't recommend you getting more
excited about it but first
to even have access get into the discord
snapshots coming that will be the first
crew
and that will give you the opportunity
and then you can decide you want to buy
it or not that's on you but i've given
you the at-bat pun intended shane novo
appreciate you guys we'll talk soon
thanks for everybody tuning in to this
breaking news candy mlb product you got
the first look here we'll see you soon
cheers gary thank you so much we really
appreciate it
happy too awesome cheers